hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over an in-game study
and i think this is one of the most
important concepts in all of chess is to
understand how to play optimally in
the in-game so you lose less and you win
more often this particular concept we're
going to be looking at is called the
ready in game we're going to go over the
concept itself and then we're going to
look at some actual games that it took
place so you can start to see how it
applies to more than just this setup now
it's white's move and white looks like
they're all but lost the white pawn on
c6 while it's pretty close to promoting
on c8s the black king is close to it and
there's no way that the plaque king is
not going to be able to take this very
easily
but you can see the black pawn on h5 it
has some separation from the white king
and how is the white king ever going to
catch this pawn from promoting to h1
seems like white is
lost
and if we play this out a little bit you
can see if white were to push forward
with c7
okay well now just b7
you can see it's not going to do much if
they come up and promote to a queen
they're just going to lose that queen if
they stop and start pushing
the king on h7 well then they just lose
their pawn and they're never going to be
able to catch
this black pawn from
promoting so it doesn't work if they
just push forward with c7 if they play
h7
okay well
black is just gonna play b6 attacking
the pawn
and if they try to push forward well
they're just gonna lose the pawn and
they still can't catch this pawn on the
h file
if they don't push forward maybe they
try to attack this pawn well as soon as
the white king gets closer
black can just continue to push this
pawn down to h1 it seems very difficult
that they could ever stop this if the
king doesn't keep pushing
then
maybe they play c7 okay well they just
lose that pawn but they're never able to
get to this pawn so how can white
actually draw this game and not lose
well that comes down to having multiple
threats from the king and it starts with
the move king to g7 now it's first look
at why this is so important so the most
common play that black could move is
king to b6 they don't have to we'll also
look at h4 as well but let's look at
king 2
b6 now white can play the move
king to f6
if black takes the pawn on c6 well you
can probably see pretty easily white can
play g5 and now they can stop the pawn
from pushing forward okay well if black
doesn't take the pawn on c6 maybe they
say okay that's not going to work i need
to start pushing my pawn here if they
play h4
white has the move king to e5 and this
entire setup
is all anchored on the fact that white
comes to e5 because now we see the
multiple threats that black has to deal
with
the first one is if black takes the pawn
on c6
well y can come to f4
and they can stop the pawn from
promoting down here
if instead
they don't take on c6 what if they come
down and play h3
well in this case white can now come to
d6 and this is the next critical square
that white's coming to and you can see
the threat that white has because they
can push forward with c7 and then they
can play c8
without worrying about black capturing
that pawn so how does black move from
now they could
play a7
and then we could just play d7 and then
push up our pawn or they could say well
i'm going to go ahead and promote to a
queen
so they play h2
and then we play c7
okay well now queen to
our pawn promoting to h1 but now we get
our own queen
so in this position we have been able to
actually
stabilize and this is going to be a
drawn game
now if we come back uh we looked at what
happens if after we come to e5 if they
play h3
we're just going to push forward with
that c7 but what if instead they decide
yeah we're just going to take that
pawn on c6 we already looked at we play
f4 and we're going to capture that pawn
so it all comes back to originally
instead of playing c7 instead of playing
h7 it all comes to the g7 square because
we're threatening coming to f6 and then
e5 so that we have two threats one of
coming to d6 helping the c6 pawn
as well as preparing to come over and
attack the pawn
on the h file black has to figure out
which side they want to deal with
but at the end of the day they are left
with a
draw so subtle moves white's
saying i can get to two different
places using a different path same
number of moves but a different path so
that's the concept we're going to start
looking at this in some actual games
so this is the next variation take a
minute pause and see if you can come up
with black's best move
now the best move for black is to play
king 2 b2 but let's first look at some
of the alternatives and why they won't
work now we have the pawn on a4 we're
trying to come down to a one in white on
f2
they can first move with pawn you can
always move two squares they're coming
to f4 and then they're going to push up
to f8
if we try to immediately come to a3
well that's not going to work because
then we they just capture our pawn and
then we start trying to catch up to
this f pawn
and we never can so that doesn't work
if we try to immediately chase this pawn
on f2 we play c2
they play a four
we try to catch it with d3 but they push
forward you can see we're never going to
catch that pawn
so let's say we change course and play
a3 okay well they're just going to
capture the pawn that's not going
to work
so
if we try to commit to either side
neither of those are the best option
the best option is to have a dual threat
and that happens to be king to b2 now we
have to look at why is that the best
option well now white has to decide
do they want to
take the pawn or do they want to push
forward if they take the pawn well now
we can actually catch this pawn on the
f-file
they play f4 we play d4 and you can see
we are going to capture that pawn
because we made them commit we had a
dual threat with our king if they don't
take the pawn
if they start pushing with f4
well not only is it not a draw
and not only are we not going to lose
but we are going to win this game
because now we have the dual threat of
a3 they can't take our pawn anymore
that's why king to b2 is so powerful
because it threatens the move of a3
so they can't take so if they start
pushing up we are going to win this race
and so after we play
a1 promote to a queen
they play f7 we play queen f1 and we are
going to take this pawn and we are going
to end up winning the game so it all
comes back to the very beginning where
where should black move they should play
king
b2
this is the last version we're going to
look at it's white's move and see if you
can pause and figure out white's best
move
now the best move for white to draw this
game is to play king g6 but first let's
look at why that is the case by looking
at some of the other alternatives now if
you look at king f6
it may look like this king is
actually in between both of the pawn
structures and so this is a better move
unfortunately though
the king needs to have multiple threats
and this king is actually getting away
from this pawn on h4
to protect this pawn it really needs to
stay on the g-file this is almost
committing to
this pawn structure or stopping these
pawns on the queen side of the board so
from here black could play pawn c4
we take they take now we can start to
bring our king involved into the action
but it's too late they play c3 we take
their pawn and after a4 we're not able
to actually
make up any ground and we can't stop
their pawn from pushing forward and
promoting to the queen on
on a1
so that's not going to work just playing
king 2 f6 it's actually
doing too much harm because it's
committing to the queen side of the
board
now instead what if we just played
h5
okay well now they take on
h5 we're still going to play that king
to f6
and we've already looked it before we're
not able to catch the pawn structure
over here now why is king to g6 any
different
well the reason is because we have
multiple threats here
what if now they take on
h4
well now we can play king to f5 a square
that our king has not been at so far
before
now if they continue with their c4 we
take they take now we play king e4
remember before is on king e5 and so now
if they play c3 we capture and they play
a4 we can easily make it down and stop
the pawn coming to a one
now if we come back after we play g6
what if they don't capture with their
king what if they decide to go ahead and
commit to the queen's header board they
play c4
well now we have the move h5 and this is
the reason that g6 is so much better
because
it stops not only the threat on the
queen side but it also supports
this h pawn from pushing up the board so
now they may recognize the king can't do
anything to this pawn this pawn is
passed and it is moving up the board you
can't stop it so now if they try to
commit to the queen side of the board
we can capture
capture but we have the pawn on h6 and
we are going to beat them
to promoting we are going to
to be okay
and this is going to be a drawing game
remember
in this initial position black should be
winning if you just look at the board
state the king is about to take the pawn
on h4
and they have three pawns to double
pawns on the b file
it's very difficult if you just look at
this at face value to think that white
can actually bring out a draw remember
all we're trying to do is get a draw
from white's standpoint so as long as we
play king to g6
doesn't matter where black plays
we're going to draw this game but if we
don't play keaney g6 if we play king to
f6 or anything else
black playing correctly is going to have
an easy victory so hopefully this ready
in-game study helps you as you approach
your owning games especially with king
and pawns which is what we're studying
right now to think about having your
king have multiple threats to put your
opponent in a position where they can't
take advantage of maybe a position where
they think they are going to win
if you did watch this entire video would
love in the comments below to put a
hundred uh every now and then i'll like
to see who made it to the very end of
the video that lets me know that you did
make it through also would like to know
in the comments if you got either of uh
the the lessons uh that lets me know
that i did a good job of teaching the
concept so if you're able to get the
first or second uh correct moves
hopefully you did please let me know in
the comments section below if there's
other tactics that you want me to focus
on if you like in-game strategy let me
know that or if you just want middle
game or opening i can do that as well
but thank you guys so much for watching
the video i'll see you guys in the next
one